[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
c'est ça vous regarde en direct et voici
le sommaire est ce une avancée pour les
femmes
au contraire la porte ouverte à une
banalisation dangereux un poste
important et lieu hier soir en
commission des affaires sociales à
l'assemblée il fait passer de 12 à 14
semaines de grossesse le délai légal
pour recourir à liv et j'ai 45 ans après
la loi veil on va s'interroger sur
l'application concrète de ce droit sur
le terrain pour certaines c'est encore
le parcours de combattant on en parle
dans un instant dans notre grand débat
moi s'arrêter aussi sur cette question
faut-il contrôler les aides aux
entreprises consacrées par le plan de
relance la controverse enfle depuis la
présentation du budget en début de
semaine le ministre michel sapin ancien
ministre de l'économie parle d'argent
public cacher alors faut-il aider toutes
les entreprises même celles qui font des
profits
ce sera dans notre face à face sur ce
plateau enfin notre grand témoin ce soir
va nous raconter sa nouvelle vie après
40 ans de journalisme il se lance en
politique avec une mission pour le moins
difficile faire renaître la démocratie
et surtout rassembler la gauche bon
courage laurent joffrin est avec nous ce
soir là non pour le programme hashtags
sévère pour réagir sur twitter tout de
suite les grands débats
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir laurent
joffrin bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes notre grand témoin on va
passer une heure ensemble les français
vous connaissent bien
vous venez tout juste de quitter il ya
quelques ya quelques mois à peine la
direction de libération pour vous lancer
en politique dans un mouvement
engageons-nous c'était au début de l'été
destinée à faire revivre la social
démocratie et pas seulement la
démocratie c'est-à-dire le courant
réformiste à gauche qui est un petit peu
moribonde à gauche de l'action la gauche
de l'action va en parler publié ce
recueil recueil de chroniques parues
dans libération et ça s'appelle anti
macro doc
et pourtant le titre ne reflète pas
exactement
non parce que le titre correspond à
l'aboutissement de cette de cette longue
histoire c'est plus subtil d'enfler au
vitriol
c'est l'éditeur qui voulaient en vendre
un peu aussi là que se dire anti ma
conscience je vois que vous dédouaner
mais si vous assumez vous nous dire et
d'ailleurs pourquoi pourquoi ce site
macrumors on va parler d'un sujet je
suis sûr qu'il vous intéresse parce que
elops et libération vos journaux de
coeur on fait des combats historiques
lives et j'ai une loi est sur le point
d'être votée
bonsoir marie-pierre x1 fort merci
d'être là vous êtes la présidente de la
délégation parlementaire aux droits des
femmes à l'assemblée député la
république en marche de l'essonne et
c'est vous qui avez voté avec d'autres
on va voir très trans partisan cette
proposition de loi sur les vg hier en
face de vous à mina yamgnane bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
gynécologue obstétricienne à l'hôpital
américain de paris et vous avez des
réserves sur ce texte vous nous en
parlera et enfin bon soir stéphane bon
sens bien dans mes fans blakowski je
précise que marianne newzy la directrice
exécutive du planning familial va nous
rejoindre dans un instant mais c'est
vous stéphane qui ouvrait le bal comme
chaque soir avec votre billet
l'actualité a bien joué le feu si j'ai
bien compris tout de suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir j'ai bien
compris
myriam en france le combat pour défendre
le droit à l'avortement se poursuit
alors priori on pourrait être un petit
peu surpris parce que pour défendre le
droit à l'avortement
il faudrait qu'il soit menacé or on n'a
pas vraiment l'impression que ce droit
soit menacée en france quand même déjà
les chiffres
premièrement les chiffres si le droit
d'avoir été menacés en france où presse
attend d'avoir un retrait des noms
d'abord taux d'avortement au dundee vg
eh ben c'est exactement le contraire
sire que le nombre des ivg augmente
régulièrement depuis 30 ans et là on a
même atteint un record l'an dernier avec
232 mille îles et j'ai alors qu'il ya
aussi un autre point de vue qui pourrait
justifier ses points de vue de la loi on
pourrait dire ya peut-être un recul au
niveau de la loi en france sur libé j'ai
maintenant en fait c'est là encore
exactement le contraire on va parler
aujourd'hui d'une proposition qui va
être votée sans doute d'ici la fin de
l'année et de ce texte à il est il doit
favoriser l'accès ivg il a été soutenu
aussi bien par les marcheurs que par les
insoumis donc à une sorte d'unanimité à
l'assemblée sur ce sujet en relief une
prévoit concrètement ce texte alors
alors en plus pas très compliqué ce
qu'ils prévoient parce qu'il prévoit en
fait de donner satisfaction aux
principales revendications des
féministes qui militait pour élargir le
droit à l'avortement tout cas pour lever
les freins donc que la première mesure
c'est d'augmenter le délai légal de
l'avortement qu'il a passée de 12 à 20
14 semaines
il ya une deuxième mesure qui s'appelle
qui consiste à supprimer la clause de la
double clause de conscience qu'est ce
que c'est sûr que un médecin peut
refuser de faire un avortement un ivg
en revanche il doit obligatoirement si
la loi est votée conseil à sa patiente
un autre médecin qui lui le fera ce qui
n'est pas forcément le cas aujourd'hui
et puis enfin une dernière un dernier
point s'est formé des sages femmes pour
qu'elles puissent faire des avortements
chirurgicaux ce qui fait que ça
permettra de soulager un peu la pénurie
de médecins qui peut exister parfois
donc avec ce texte logo france il ya
plus aucune raison d'aller tester des
raisons de manier testé on en trouve
toujours me rien nous allons par exemple
on peut manifester pour soutenir les
femmes argentines qui elles manifestent
pour obtenir le droit à l'avortement
on peut aussi modifier le pardon
manifester pour pour changer la loi
par grand beau pays bas le délai légal
il est 22 semaines alors pourrait
manifester pour pourquoi pas nous en
france allait jusqu'à 22 semaines
cinq mois et demi un canton quand on est
vraiment décidés à manifester pour
défendre le droit à l'avortement on
trouve toujours une revendication voilà
par exemple une revendication que j'ai
entendu fois sur facebook
lors d'une manifestation qui avait lieu
ce week end à paris j'aimerais bien
aussi pays européens qui persiste à
refuser purement et simplement interdire
ni vg qui sont par exemple le match
andorre monaco le liechtenstein
le vatican et sans à 20 sont des pays
européens le léger d'intention c'est
scandaleux que tu es un indice purement
et simplement l'idée
alors c'est important de défendre droit
à l'avortement mais quand on en est à
défend le droit de l'avortement à monaco
halliche d'einstein et même au vatican
c'est vraiment un vrai combat pour le
camp du progrès c'est d'obtenir que le
pape autorisent l'avortement les bonnes
soeurs mais je me demande si le combat
féministe devrait pas trouver finalement
d'autres priorités que celle ci marc
ibérique sein qui les provoquent un ce
soir il volontairement simplement est-ce
que moi les ce qu'il est vraiment
prioritaire ce combat ce combat il est
prioritaire alors moyen des fiches
présidente de la délégation aux droits
des femmes il ya 18 mois nous avons
lancé une mission d'information
parce que nous nous sommes rendu compte
que ce droit à l'avortement
il était certes garantie par la loi mais
que finalement c'était un droit qui
était toléré est pas véritablement un
droit entier et aujourd'hui ce droit il
n'est pas effectif pour un grand nombre
de femmes sur notre territoire et je
pense monsieur en particulier aux femmes
qui habitent des zones rurales par
exemple et pour lesquelles le droit à
l'avortement n'est pas simple alors est
l'objet de cette proposition de loi est
bien de rendre ce droit effectuée c'est
vrai que quand on voit les combats et
les avancées des combats féministes
aujourd'hui le mythe ou les féminicides
la question des violences conjugales des
agressions sexuelles
on se dise ce combat là il est aussi
urgent que les eaux il est aussi urgent
parce que la possibilité pour une femme
de maîtriser la fécondité sa maternité
c'est la condition même de sa liberté et
celle de pouvoir mener sa vie telle
qu'elle l'entend c'est un combat fort
qui a effectivement été menée par simone
veil dans des conditions que nous
connaissons et il s'agit pas de faire
une nouvelle loi pour faire une nouvelle
loi mais bien de faire rentrer en sorte
que ce droit soit garanti et les
conditions de cette loi entendons nous
bien et n'agit pas d'élargir le nombre
d'avortements est d'ailleurs au fur et à
mesure de la législation nous avons
élargi les conditions d'accès à diriger
pour autant je suis pas d'accord avec
monsieur le nombre division en france et
à peu près stable
autour de 230 me l'apporté la rumba on
va y venir on va regarder les
difficultés puisque vous parlez
d'effectivité des droits mais simplement
avant de nous donner votre position sur
les 12 et 14 semaines
madame yamgnane vous qui pratiquez à
l'hôpital des interruptions volontaires
de grossesse et des choses à améliorer
vous diriez ça déjà je crois même en
préambule je dirais que d'abord je viens
parler ici au nom du collège national
des gynécologues obstétriciens qui est
le collège qui régit la façon dont les
gynécologues obstétriciens travail donc
nous on a été très surpris parce qu'on
n'a pas été consultée même sur cette
proposition de loi
et c'est vrai que voilà je je laurent
joffrin est là comme témoin c'est une
drôle de façon de pratiquer la politique
parce que en l'occurrence on a voté pour
la rm qui a proposé que la société
civile rentrer qu'on les embarquent dans
les discussions et là ce qu'on voit
c'est que les d'alerté sont leurs choix
vous allez direct sur le texte mcmillon
s'éteignent at il des choses encore à
améliorer quand on est sur les rameuses
à améliorer la deuxième pour l'avenir
législateur n'a pas complètement tort
devant délire du restic environ 230
milles ivg par an en france
il n'est pas sérieux de dire que l'accès
est menacée dans son effectivité
ce n'est pas sérieux c'est un argument
qui tient pas la route un arc en ciel tu
ans mais vous pouvez pas dire que c'est
pas effectif 6 250 mille familles ont
accès combien n'y ont pas accès me
gagnon pas forcément accès dans les
conditions mêmes de la loi puisque vous
savez vous-même que dans la loi il est
notamment notifié que les femmes ont le
choix de la méthode madame pourra peut
être en retard n'est tout à l'heure or
aujourd'hui les femmes n'ont pas
nécessairement le choix de la méthode la
leaf est d'allonger alors le délai va
t'il à matane est
vous allez tout de suite sur le fond moi
je voudrais commencer à accueillir maria
news dit bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
est à directif exécutif du planning
familial c'est vous qui coordonné
l'ensemble des différents organismes de
planning familial sur le territoire donc
vous avez aussi un point de vue de
terrain à nous à nous donner
on comprend que vous n'êtes pas d'accord
effectivement le recours à lever j'ai
augmenté dans notre pays mais ça reste
difficile pour certaines femmes
lesquelles on voit cela avec hradecka 45
ans après la légalisation de l'ivg et
j'ai avorté reste pour certaines femmes
un parcours de combattante
le constat est là il est de plus en plus
difficile de trouver un interlocuteur
dans un délai rapide
ces dix dernières années 130
établissements spécialisés dans libé
j'ai offert mais il faut dire que la
pratique n'est pas rentable en moyenne
entre 400 et 600 euros le même acte
médical est facturé 1300 euros lorsqu'il
s'agit d'une fausse couche
et puis les femmes doivent affronter la
pénurie de médecins
les militants de l'avortement sont
partis à la retraite et la jeune
génération n'a pas vraiment pris la
relève il n'y a pas de données chiffrées
mais selon la délégation aux droits des
femmes
ils pratiqueraient mon lit vg la clause
de conscience spécifique au droit à
l'avortement leur permet de refuser cet
acte sans avoir à le justifier
qu'en est il du délai les femmes peuvent
avorter jusqu'à la douzième semaine de
grossesse
un obstacle de plus pour les
associations qui juge cette limite trop
courte
chaque année entre trois et cinq mille
femmes vont apporter à l'étranger pour
avoir dépassé les délais en france
alors madame nosy 3 à 5000 femmes qui
vont à l'étranger parce que ce délai est
dépassé c'est pour elle qu'il faut
changer la loi notamment pour elle parce
que ce sont le plus souvent des femmes
qui ont pu vivre une grossesse non
désirée pour des raisons tout à fait
pédestre est là les raisons qui sont 7
des femmes d'habitude c'est à dire une
méthode de contraception qui n'a pas
fonctionné
voilà un choix qui se révèle plutôt
mauvais étant donné l'évolution du
couple des choses qui arrivent à toutes
les femmes et qui se transforme
l'avortement se transforme soudainement
d'une décision qui devrait être tout à
fait voilà accompagné normale en drame
puisqu'elles doivent quitter le pays
dépenser des sommes très importantes et
pour certaines d'entre elles n'y
arriveront pas est ce que est ce que ça
existe encore en france des femmes qui
parce qu'elles n'ont pas les moyens
peut-être de prendre un billet d'avion
pour aller se faire avorter à l'étranger
sont obligée d'accoucher
alors que c'est des grossesses non
désirées est ce que ça existe encore ça
ou pas du tout travaillé et j'en ai déjà
que j'en ai déjà rencontré des femmes
dont je j'ai eu la crainte quand elle
quittait notre centre qu'elle ne prenne
l'avortement entre leurs mains donc qui
m'ont supplié de leur trouver une
solution parce qu'elle ne pouvait pas
quitter le territoire par exemple on
parle de femmes sans papiers
quelles sont les principales argent
difficulté j'imagine qu'il ya une
fracture rurale urbaine selon qu'on est
jeune ou plus plus mûr selon qu on entre
on est seul ou quand l'autre a sonné
avec sa famille les profils des femmes
qui souhaitent avorter après 12 semaines
de grossesse sont assez semblable à
celui des autres donc c'est des femmes
qui ont voilà une méthode de
contraception qui n'a pas fonctionné
des règles irrégulières d un travail
très prenant qui fait qu'elles se sont
pas trop rendu compte
on voit pas ne sais pas expliquer sa
part l'axé social force alors après
personnellement j'ai un petit billet
mais je pense qu au planning dans les
raisons moi j'ai travaillé en région ile
de france donc c'est vrai que
globalement la ruralité très
périphérique en région ile de france
mais c'est vrai que dans notre région et
madame rixin avait bien raison de
l'évoquer en fait la distance et le fait
qu'il existe peu d'hôpitaux et de
services de médecins dans ces endroits
là fait qu'on peut facilement dépasser
les délais et devoir se rendre à d'être
alors marc hébert exemple pourquoi c'est
indispensable selon vous de passer de 12
à 14 semaines
alors est-ce que vous allez peut-être il
y est voilà parés de la france qui ce
texte disons le en traitement correspond
à deux objectifs le premier est me
semble-t-il est celui de resituer dans l
interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans un parcours de santé de femmes une
femme sur trois sur quatre à peu près
connaît une ivg au cours de sa vie l'a
fait partir du son du parcours de santé
d'un grand nombre de femmes dans notre
pays et donc il fallait le resituer dans
ce contexte là si vous le voulez bien je
parlerai d'abord delà de la suppression
de la double clause qui encore une fois
il n'ya pas de supra techniques non il
ne s'agit pas de suaves et mais il ya
deux clauses ya une clause de conscience
pour les médecins qui peuvent refuser un
acte médical il ya une cause spécifique
pour refuser une iv sur l'a7 deuxième
l'art qu'on supprime mais elle rend
obligatoire un médecin comme nous l'a
bien expliqué et sur les femmes tout à
l'heure surtout elle n'enlève aucun
droit aux professionnels de santé c'est
un professionnel de santé évidemment
qu'ils refuseraient à juste titre pour
des raisons personnelles de pratiquer
une ivg pourra toujours le refuser en
revanche il sera contraint d'orienter
une femme vers un professionnel qui le
pratiquent donc ça c'est un droit pour
les femmes et non pas un droit en moins
pour les médecins doutent c'est un port
14 mai les douze à quatorze semaines
rappelons le nous le disons dans le
rapport de la délégation aux droits des
femmes concerne à l'étranger un petit
nombre de femmes
soyons francs il concerne environ 0 5 %
des ivg dans les pays qui le connaissent
mais c'est 0 5% de femmes se sont en
effet des femmes qui quoi qu'il arrive
vivront cette ivg et donc il s'agit de
leur permettre de le vivre dans des
conditions correctes et sur le
territoire national c'est pas cela qui
va rendre plus accessible ivg et c'est
en aucun cas ce qui va augmenter le
nombre diriger ce qui est important
aujourd'hui et ce sera probablement le
troisième point sur lequel nous allons
échanger c'est de rendre cette
interruption de l'entière de grossesse
accessible pour toutes les femmes et
dans le cadre des dispositions de la loi
j'insiste c'est à dire en tous lieux une
femme doit pouvoir apporter gay et selon
la norme éditoriale et selon l'amith à
jon hamm 1 mais voilà la méthode alors
le seul homme de ce plateau
oui quel est votre regard à laurent
joffrin ce débat c'est vrai qu'on peut
s'étonner on se dit finalement cela est
derrière vous non ça vous étonne pas
mais non parce que c'est un cas c'est
classique il ya d'autres droits comme ça
qu'ils existent qui s'est pas eu droit
au droit finalement l'accès au droit
j'ai par exemple qui n'a rien à voir le
rsa c'est un droit tout le monde peut
aller au rsa vous regardez dans les
fêtes mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui
courent et qui ne le font pas alors il
ya mille raisons
et ça c'était c'est une chose très
importante même 45 ans avait en plus la
critique de de la loi est quand même
difficile parce que imaginons que il ya
très peu de femmes que qui du coup
avortent alors que le faisait pas
auparavant ce cas là la loisne ne fait
pas de mal elle ouvre un droit un peu
plus largement et puis accueil à ces
concerne que sam mais les pommes sega
n'a plus que ça vraiment il ya là jean
milliers qui ont du mal à accéder
un droit qui existe depuis 50 ans quand
même et qui est admis par toute la
société française fin par la grande
majorité de la société française et par
la représentation nationale et donc le
fait de faciliter l'accès
ce droit me paraît élémentaire et c'est
arielle droit pour la politique c'est
important parce que souvent les
politiques semblent utiles disent bon on
a fait une loi et donc ça va c'est un
avancé de faire une loi qui avait pas de
loi avant mais après il faut se
préoccuper de la manière dont elle est
appliquée c'est souvent les gens se
disent billets location l'examen ce
qu'on voit comment on fait
je saisis au vol
en 2000 le planning familial a fait la
même a dit il faudrait reculer le délai
dit vigier de douze à quatorze semaines
parce que 3500 à 5000 femmes
s'ils n'ont pas le temps d'arriver à al
hadath ont besoin d'aller à l'étranger
ça a été fait et on se retrouve vingt
ans plus tard avec le même nombre dans
les mêmes conditions
je prends le pari je voudrais terminer
tranquillement on sera au même point la
question n'est pas là et surtout surtout
la faire et que en 2000 que les français
sachent bien quand le délai de l'hiver
et a été augmenté et que ça devient
techniquement pour les gynécologues a
l'air de l'eau à la deux le fait et ma
question vous pour me présenter les
pratiques et bien je vous le ferai je le
ferai je termine ma démonstration
ce n'est pas une démonstration je
termine de transmettre les faits et les
chiffres en 2001 quand la loi aubry a
voté un recul de 2 semaines comme
techniquement c'est glauque et qu' on
est dans la trivialité des choses 30%
des gynécologues qui pratiquent l ivg
ont arrêté de le faire on est 30 % de
moins aujourd'hui qu'on était il ya
vingt ans pour travaux n'est l'hexagone
dans la technique de et a donc et donc
au delà de cette question
cette loi ce qu'elle a fait c'est
qu'elle a diminué
l'offre et on se retrouve évidemment
vingt ans plus tard dans la même
situation est donc regarder que notre
produit pour eux pour cette loi
recommençons il va y avoir très
probablement beaucoup de gynéco qui vont
renoncer de le faire et on sera plus
mais bon même une question où je termine
de notre point de vue les gynécologues
il nous semble que quand une femme
arrive pour 2 a pris la décision de
demander une ivg et que le délai moyen
est de 3 semaines
si la limite est à 14 semaines toutes
les femmes qui mettent plus de six
semaines à se décider à faire une ivg ou
qui arrivent au delà de 11 semaines pour
demander une ivg se retrouvent defacto
au delà du délai donc la question n'est
pas de sans cesse reculer ce délai la
question est de faire en sorte que nos
services de santé que nous finançons
tous avec nos impôts puissent permettre
aux femmes d'avoir le moratois moi mon
point de vue là où vous auriez de
l'utilité puissante
et de dire non quand une femme demande
une ivg il faut que le délaisse maximum
ces quatre jours à l'exécution se fait
rapidement derrière je réponds c'est
certain je ris je réponds à votre
question partenaires trouvent que je
fais les ivg et je fais des ivg d'
indications médicales aussi pour des
enfants qui sont porteurs de
malformations donc moi personnellement
je suis bien placé pour savoir de quoi
il s'agit je fais d interruption
médicale de grossesse jusqu'à terme y
compris sur des baies 3 kg donc c'est
pas moi qui vont venir la faire je suis
parfaitement capacités techniques et
éthiques et philosophiques et de
compétences de l'est à cette clause de
conscience et que vous ne l'aimez et
médecins pourraient au fond du cd
davantage vous personnellement ma
question elle porte sur le choix
personnel vous le feriez mais moi je ne
pas perdre mais personnellement j'aurais
pas de problème à ce que la question et
qu'on va pas appuyer une politique de
santé très clair ma position personnelle
non mais c'est pas trop ça mais bien sûr
je crois que marc était riche moi je ne
suis pas je ne suis pas législateur pour
opposer les uns aux autres il s'agit pas
aujourd'hui de poser les gynécologues
obstétriciens aux femmes qui
souhaiteraient vivre une interruption
volontaire de grossesse pour en effet
différentes raisons qui leur appartient
or aujourd'hui madame nous avons fait
encore une fois une étude sur à peu près
18 mois sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
sachez est en effet puisque vous prenez
à témoin les français et je le redis
également sachez que sur un certain
nombre de territoires
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est que les
femmes n'ont pas accès à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse prothèse parce
que certains professionnels de santé en
effet ne souhaite plus l'exercer mais
également parce qu'il ya un
problématiques de formation de
démographie médicale soyons francs et
que ce qui est important pour une femme
qui vit n'intéresse angleterre de
grossesse et d'être accompagné et je
suis tombé à madame qui vous dit qu'au
fond la loi voire avoir un effet
contraire à l'entrée des pénuries de
médecins
l'ex n importe quoi en tout cas l'auteur
dénonce à l'important aujourd'hui c'est
que les femmes elles soient accompagnés
par des professionnels qui les
connaissent qui sont techniquement armée
pour pouvoir procéder à cette
interruption volontaire de grossesse et
qui souhaitent les accompagner ce que
vous faites aujourd'hui eon
vous en vous en sais gré mais ça c'est
très important et c'est du tout
l'intérêt de l'ouvrir notamment aux
sages femmes qui connaissent très bien
le corps des femmes peut-être mieux que
certains internes et qui seront très
bien pratiquer ses intérêts que les
sages femmes elles aussi sont concernés
par parce tu acquiers loi au gabon le
grand public en soixante ans du délai
légal les sages femmes jusqu'à dix
semaines pourront pratiquer des ivg donc
vous l'argument de médecins qui
finalement risquerait d'être moins
nombreux ils ne pèsent pas pour vous non
parce que nous en fait si justement on
est autour de la table aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de médecins qui
soutiennent en fait ce projet de loi des
médecins qui travaillent au planning des
médecins qui voient là qu'il faut
repartir d'autres organisations
professionnelles qui ne sont pas
effectivement le collège national et qui
disent que oui effectivement les deux
semaines supplémentaires leur convient
on ne ferait pas en fait on n'aurait pas
ce débat aujourd'hui ci avait pas
consensus et président du collège
national des gynécologues
oui le collègue de madame diane est
également contre sur les mêmes pour les
mêmes il était contre en 2001 aussi je
souligne d'accord il est donc pour vous
il ya un gros 55 ans dans la communauté
médicale et pour eux conservés point de
la méthode
je me permet quand même de dire que dans
le cadre du travail de la délégation aux
droits des femmes
le collège évidemment a été associé nous
avons sollicité le collège pour venir
devant la délégation aux droits des
femmes que l'ensemble des décors ont été
auditionnées et un grand nombre de
visites sur le terrain ont également été
réalisés donc on peut pas non plus dire
que ce travail a été réalisé en catimini
d'air le dos de la société civile
puisqu'il est le fruit de 18 de la
délégation aux droits des femmes
j'ai du mal à me faire comprendre c'est
pas moi la question je pense que ce
débat vous plus qu'un débat sur la
technique
oui absolument d'ailleurs le travail que
la délégation n'est pas sur la méthode
la concertation a eu d'après les
parlementaires j'ai une question toute
simple on s'aligne sur l'espagne ça se
passe bien en espagne ça va être le même
allez demander aux gynécologues le type
de complication qu'ils ont sur les ivg
réalisées tardivement pardonnez moi un
point d'angleterre c'est un point très
important je crois que ces problèmes le
point le plus important le fait
exclusivement mais le troisième point le
fait de l'ouvrir aux sages femmes
est un point crucial parce que nous
allons donc offrir ouvrir par dont le
nombre de professionnels pratiquant
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
donc 2,7
l'offre va être renforcé les femmes très
probablement vont pouvoir être
accueillis et accompagnés dans les plus
brefs délais et donc vous savez très
bien que les complications sur les ivg
ont lieu lorsqu elles sont pratiquées
plus tardivement non plus les femmes
seront accompagnés dans les dents les
premiers des premiers délai est plus
l'offre sera importante - les
complications iron seront là mais parce
que ça fait pas très bien vous savez
très bien que ce point il est
déterminant sur la sécurité également
des femmes les plans médical en matière
d'intérêts madame vous voyez vous me
dites vous même
ça sort de votre bouche plus on fait des
ivg tardives plus c'est dangereux pour
les femmes et vous vous portez une loi
qui augmente le délai parce que alors
que ben c'est à dire que maintenant vous
savez très bien que je voudrais je
voudrais aider là je vous aiderai hélas
ce délai là on l'a dit concerne un
pourcentage très faible de femmes jeu et
celles ci seront en effet accompagné par
des allergologues et vous répondez vous
l'avez dit vous-même suis à terme
wallace jr je voudrais parce qu'en
pratique mais on pratique chalaron
pratiquer des avortements tardifs en
france vous le dites vous même parce que
le pays le la france est un des pays qui
pratiquent le plus d'interruption
médicale de grossesse bien moi j'en
conviens mais fessier mais elles sont
formées à sa voilà moi j'aimerais bien
qu'on m'explique ce plan on peut
pratiquer dmg pourquoi la hollande le
royaume-uni les etats-unis parce qu'on
rit beaucoup des états unis il n'y a pas
de délai aux états unis on va jouer à
l'inter au colorado
ces leçons des erreurs voilà ça dépend
des états mais c'est vrai qu'à madaya
pas moins les six mois jusqu'à six mois
voilà pourquoi on n'est pas du tout la
ré pas faire la même chose pourquoi
est-ce qu'on nous oppose en fait une
complication technique parce que le
collège oppose des complications
techniques en fait due voilà les deux
collèges des gynécologues collège des
gynécologues alors que sur plein
d'autres aspects on le pratique nous
voisins le pratique c'est pas sorcier
non mais c'est vrai qu'on se dit
d'autant plus de quatorze semaines alors
qu'au royaume uni ces six mois on n'en
est pas du tout là c'est ma grossesse
oui mais voilà on n'est pas dans les
mêmes techniques alors un de travail se
sont - on déballe là toutes ces
histoires la technique ou français qui
nous écoutent mais on ne parle pas de la
même chose
une anglaise bassesse à 24 semaines
c'est pas la libérer c'est facile et
pasquet dans la loi ces travaux
même que de la nano est pas nous devrons
pas un débat qui n'a pas de comparer ce
domaine on n'est pas sur cet exemple la
faune dise les choses très clairement je
vous fait accouché une femme à 24
semaines dans le cadre d'une ivg
l'enfant est né vivant on est mis en
valeur
mini des vivants oui mais attends mais
pas la meuse vous avez voulu parler des
anglais allons au bout ce n'est pas par
les dix ans jusque là les gens voudront
pas que je suis une boîte de pandore qui
agit la dre voudrait que des armes
expliqué jusqu'au bout je vous en prie
mais parlons de ce qui est dans la loi
ni ou mais c'est vous qui m'avez amenée
en angleterre aux états-unis moi j'ai
rien demandé moi ce que je veux dire
c'est que on est apple revenons cette
france là où d'autres les ne sont pas
formés aux techniques chirurgicales qui
va les former sur quel temps de travail
elle saft sur ce n est fait
mr un stérilet c'est pas pareil a l'air
un curetage alors je voudrais terminer
sur quel ton travail qui va les former
et sur la question des moyens et
vinalines et revient tous vos permanence
vous dites vous même si les femmes
pouvaient être accueillis plutôt en plus
grand nombre
on n'aurait pas besoin d'aller si loin
et c'est c'est tout le sens d'introduire
les sages-femmes exemple célestin à les
produire et ça j'aime les sages femmes
sont déjà en titre ce débat s'est ouvert
sur les moyens à l'hôpital fait viable
vont être accompagnés pour se former à
ces nouvelles techniques est ce qui aura
des moyens c'est la question des moyens
qui est voisin sur et d'ailleurs elles
sont extrêmement volontaire et n'agit
pas encore une fois de contraindre les
sages femmes à pratiquer des ivg et
soyons clairs selon les sages femmes qui
sont désireuses d'accompagner les femmes
qui pratiqueront ses dirigeants qu'il
agit en aucun cas ne montre indre des
élèves sages femmes ou des sages-femmes
de prêts très clair question politique
pour terminer ce texte il a toutes les
chances d'être adoptée dans l'hémicycle
cette proposition de loi avec malice et
le gouvernement reste assez en retrait
on n'est pas leader s'il a été adopté en
commission donc et vous l'avez dit
vous-même dans votre documentaire je
crois qu'il ya une unanimité sur les sur
les bancs donc je suis je ne suis pas le
gouvernement je suis pas vous dire
aujourd'hui quelle est la position que
vous a dit olivier ferrand lamé
1948 la vague sur la sur la sur les
parlementaires les parlementaires seront
présents en force le 8 octobre pour
voter c'est bon c'est grâce à laurent
joffrin dernière question pour clore ce
débat on est sur le sociétal et on voit
que voilà ça change la vie ça change la
vie au quotidien
la semaine dernière c'était le congé
paternité
aujourd'hui on parle de 10 vg au fond
c'est pas ces sujets là finalement qui
font la politique aujourd'hui le reste
on se rend pas forcément compte des
changements mais là c'est immédiat et ça
fait réagir
c'est manifestement et concrets et
immédiats et de vie quotidienne mais il
ya d'autres sujets si on vous laisse
votre salaire j'ai les médias précieux
personne ne baisse les salaires en
dessous du smic en france
non mais c'est vrai que ces sujets
saisirait de société proposé le sujet
comme ça se prête une place de plus en
plus importante parce que finalement on
se dit que c'est le fait qu il ya un
lien entre les femmes qui ne qui
n'arrivent pas à accéder à ce droit et
leur condition sociale donc pas
nécessaire
eh ben c'est sûrement mais il ya des
papiers qui se retrouve hors des délais
de la transition mesdames je pense que
tous les arguments étaient mis sur étape
je vous remercie infiniment on va parler
un petit peu de vous de votre projet
politique redonner vie aux idées
sociales-démocrates est une chance pour
la gauche en 2022 c'est parti
et donc vous publier ce livre pour vous
construire la gauche anti macro recueil
de chroniques parues dans libération je
le disais c'est plus fin que le titre
mais vous disiez aussi et c'est pas à
vous qu'on va pas apprendre l'importance
d'un titre mais franchement c'est ce que
je chante et je suis arrivé à cette
conclusion
ça veut dire quoi cette posture ses
savates vous êtes maintenant dans une
position où je banal voix mais
l'opposition c'est ça fait un programme
être anti mac os enfin le ce livre est
le recueil des chroniques que j'ai fait
dans libération qui sont du crédit des
chroniques vivante si possible il redit
qu un peu drôle parce que la politique
n'est pas obligé de toujours ennuyeux zh
il est fort ce titre deux ans que poser
de façon claire et nette contre le
président réseau vente c'est que au
début c'était séduisant pour beaucoup de
gens en tout cas vous avez quelqu'un qui
disait on va prendre des deux côtés à
droite et à gauche
ce qui est bien ou ce qui nous paraît
bien bien offert une synthèse
intelligente et on va renouveler la vie
politique
mais ça c'est pas du tout passé comme ça
quand on regarde les premières mesures
elles ont favorisé plutôt les favorisés
quand même et quant aux réformes elles
ont souvent pas toujours la forme
sociale je ne le nie pas mais il ya eu
des réformes les plus spectaculaires ont
porté atteinte à beaucoup d'acquis
sociaux
et puis il ya eu ces phrases qui sont
pas seulement des maladresses qui sont
des phrases spontanée et qui qui
traduisait une forme de condescendance
envers les gens de peu donc ça donnait
des remous sociaux très un petit il ya
eu des mesures qui nous conviennent pas
bien et qui me convient très bien
mais globalement parlant on arrive à une
france qui est plus divisée beaucoup
plus divisée aujourd'hui qu'elle n'était
au départ est d'ailleurs resté dans les
chiffres qui est plus inégale et où la
justice sociale sauf sur certains points
ils disent où tout le monde est
classique mesures mais globalement la
justice sociale n'a pas été favorisé par
ce mandat
on va en parler le titre vous essayez de
travail et un projet pour la gauche et
rassembler la gauche la question c'est
jusqu'où pour l'instant c'est la gauche
façon puzzle c'est dommage parce que il
ya un espace politique pour gagner en
2022 on voit cela avec nathalie gay
loire voici la photo de famille des
ailes de la gauche une famille
aujourd'hui morcelé éclaté façon puzzle
est le seul qui avait réussi à recoller
ces pièces c'est françois mitterrand le
programme ouvert à toutes les
organisations démocratiques à tous les
citoyens qui voudront bien se placer
dans le cadre de l'union de la gauche et
de son combat nécessaire les trois
partis de gauche étaient représentés par
leur leader une image qui fait rêver
laurent joffrin qui ce 20 juillet a
lancé son mouvement les engager
je veux d'abord déclenché un mouvement
qui vient de la société pour élaborer un
projet de transformation sociale
crédible qui puisse servir de plateforme
pour une victoire en 2022
autour d'une gauche dure et elle
première mission dont pour laurent
joffrin faire taire la guerre des chefs
qui fait rage à gauche
ce que je vous dis c'est que pour gagner
l'élection présidentielle future
il faut un candidat unique pour
l'ensemble de la gauche et des
écologistes
un candidat oui mais lequel le temps des
écologistes est venu ils ont eu leur
chance
les socialistes les libéraux
les républicains ils ont eu leur chance
et les ont failli pourquoi nous plutôt
que d'autres mais je n'ai déjà dit le
premier avec les écologistes pour nous
pas l'écologie c'est le social et si
tout cela pense que le parti communiste
français comme en 2017 et en 2012 ne
présenteront pas de candidat eh bien je
dis à tout le monde
eh bien vous vous trompez dans ces
conditions cette gauche semble bien
irréconciliables selon manuel valls je
peins pense qu'on peut refaire d'une
manière ou d'une autre la gauche chloé
alifax tout le monde sait pas c'est pas
le sujet on peu plus avec cette gauche
là je parle pas des électeurs je parle
de ces appareils
ces militants sans compter que d'autres
ténors pourrait s'inviter dans la course
à la présidentielle comme anne hidalgo
françois hollande et même christiane
taubira ce morcellement de la gauche qui
n'est pas d'ailleurs que sur les
personnes qui correspond aussi à des
images de fond ça vous désespère ou pas
pas du tout je suis désespéré je ne
serais pas ce que je fais alors le
rassemblement vous le voyez comment en
deux temps la gauche n'a jamais gagné
quand le troisième courant celui dont je
me réclame qui est un courant de
l'action c'est à dire de la réforme mais
la gauche réformiste qu'on appelait
social démocrate l'a jamais chronique
sans que ce courant soit fort n'existe
pas et il n'est plus majoritaire à
gauche il n'est plus majorité absolue
d'où ma démarche faut essayer de
renouveler le réinventer de le dépasser
et de l'unifier c'est la première fauche
et jusqu'où les sociaux démocrates avec
qui je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
citoyens qui ceci et qui se situe le
citoyenne qui se situe entre l'écologie
et macron je laisse de côté la france a
soumises qui veut de toute manière
présenter un candidat
la peine de satie
donc le rassemblement c'est sain
mélenchon oui alors moi qui change de
vie tout est possible on ne sait jamais
sur quoi il faudrait qu'ils changent
d'avis mais attendez si je termine une
fois que vous avez si on arrive à réunir
les gens qui sont qui vont de l'écologie
à macron parti écologique dont on vous a
déjà une force importante
il ya beaucoup de gens il ya beaucoup de
bonnes idées de macron s'il est déçu on
vise aujourd'hui kidman le seront plus
allez savoir
et donc là vous avez beaucoup de monde
si vous prenez les déçus du maquereau
dit ça fait quand même du monde
si vous prenez les gens qui ont voté
socialiste qui ne le font plus vous
demande et donc tous ces gens là il faut
leur proposer un projet il faut proposer
des idées des propositions qu'ils soient
neufs qui soit et qui soit crédible
c'est à dire quand on sait qu'une fois
qu'on est au pouvoir on tient la
promesse parce que faire défaire des
grandes promesses est arrivé au pouvoir
vous savez j'ai regardé les comptes ya
pas d'argent on peut pas le faire car ce
que vous défendez sur le fond au-delà
des personnes ont appris qu'ils étaient
nombreux les candidats potentiels
l'europe
non vous descendez vous êtes favorable à
une économie de marché 10 ou qu'elles
soient régulés réguler les marchés
d'aujourd'hui absolument vous n'êtes pas
favorable à la décroissance donc
clairement vous pensez qu'on peut faire
confiance au progrès à la science et à
la croissance de vos lieux de dévotion
labs dont jours certes mais en tout cas
la science change et le diffuse sa
changé mais mais vous pensez que la
croissance et le progrès peut nous
permettre d'avoir des outils qui ont
décroché au cyanure polluants et croître
le secteur propre laïque aussi se trouve
la résultante sera une croissance
républicain oui universalis oui oui mais
dans la salle a aussi renouvelé
prenons universaliste républicain les
gens disent ou alors c'est abstrait ces
anciens et c'est vrai que cet ancien
sadate de 1792 à peu près donc c'est
très anciens effectivement mince et nos
principes
mais si on s'en tient à ces gens là en
raison il faut que la promesse
républicaine d'égalité des chances entre
les gens qui sont issues de certains
quartiers qui sont issus d'autres
quartiers deviennent réelles
et pour qu'elle devienne réel il faut
des procédures quand on a dit il faut
que les femmes accèdent à l'égalité on a
fait la parité pas partout ma forme a
essayé de faire dans certains secteurs
n'a pas été si on n'avait pas fait ça
n'aurait pas marché donc il faut trouver
des procédures je dis pas que c'est la
même procédure
pas forcément des quotas mais en tout
cas il faut faire en sorte que les gens
qui sont issus des quartiers populaires
ou des villages qui sont mal desservis
qui sont qu'ils sont écartés abandonné
il faut que ces gens là accèdent à des
responsabilités pour le faire il ne
suffit pas de dire c'est le même droit
pour tout le monde
il faut des procédures je prends un
exemple dans mon journal libération
celui que j'ai dirigé pendant longtemps
on a on a fait une enquête combien y
at-il de fils d'ouvriers combatif deux
fils d'employé cette enquête faisons-le
enquête ces minuscules et ultra
minoritaire alors gagnant dans la
population quand je vous entends le
combat pour l'égalité des chances et sa
densité pas chez makro il avale
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait du chemin
mais qu'est-ce qu'il a fait précis
dédoublement des classes c'est très bien
par exemple moi je connais trois ans
qu'il faut aller beaucoup plus loin
c'est à dire pendant les procédures de
stage se font par cooptation aujourd'hui
donc les gens ont fait venir en stage
les gens qu'on connaît comme le comme
ceux qui sont en place
en général ils sont de classe moyenne ou
supérieure mais ils prennent des
stagiaires qui viennent du même endroit
donc faut il faut il faut des procédures
et on travaille là dessus se dit je ne
dis pas que j'ai toutes les solutions
mais en tout cas le
le ca ça renouvelle la culture de la
social démocratie classique parce que ce
sont les valeurs républicaines
il n'y a pas de quotas ethniques là
dedans il n'y a pas de discrimination
positive mais il ya une volonté précise
de faire en sorte que l'égalité des
chances ne soit pas un vain mot alors
justement pour rebondir sur cette
question de la social démocratie je
salue réservé les bourses
bonsoir soit un écart dans cette
émission du quotidien le temps quotidien
suite et vous avez deux trois choses à
dire à laurent joffrin dernier
social-démocrate notre pays
eh bien oui parce que effectivement
laurent joffrin veut renouveler la
social démocratie comme il vient de
l'expliquer mais regardons un peu ce qui
se passe à côté de la france au-delà de
nos frontières alors il ya quelque chose
que les téléspectateurs ne savent
peut-être pas c'est que l' orange
laurent joffrin est très féru d'histoire
il est spécialiste de napoléon en contre
il a écrit notamment la libre sur la
bataille de waterloo où il explique qu
in extremis ça s'est joué vraiment à la
fin et bien napoléon aurait pu
l'emporter mais ce n'a pas été lui c'est
wellington alors quand on regarde la
social démocratie en europe 1 on se dit
que quand même c'est plutôt waterloo
partout on regarde quand on regarde
l'allemagne par exemple c'est le bastion
historique de la social démocratie
alors elle a réussi le spd a réussi à
faire 37 % aux dernières élections
régionales à hambourg mais très
franchement il revient de très loin et
c'était un de ses bastions
parce que aux dernières européennes 15 %
15 % ces cinq pour cent de moins que les
grünen les verts allemands et il y a eu
cette débâcle des dernières législatives
en 2017
avec pourtant un plan d'avenir qui
ressemblait d'ailleurs un peu à ce que
vous proposez alors allons voir du côté
de l'espagne là il y a un président du
conseil socialiste au pouvoir pedro
sanchez mais il est totalement ligoté il
n'y arrive pas la seule chance qu'il en
ce moment c'est que son allié radical à
savoir podemos est en plus mauvaise
posture
regardons du côté de l'italie là c'est
simple le vocabulaire socialiste ou
social-démocrate a juste complètement
disparu de la carte politique alors il
reste certes le portugal un parti
socialiste qui a toujours été très
centriste et qui continue de l'être
il reste évidemment la scandinavie mais
moi la question que j'ai envie de poser
à laurent joffrin lui qui attend scruter
la bataille de waterloo est ce que vous
n'êtes quand même pas là des derniers
grognards comme lors de cet
ce que vous me suggérer au fond c'est
qu'il faut être du côté du manche non
sans l'autre critère votre critère c'est
de savoir qui est fort qui est faible
comme je suis du côté du faible j'ai
tort ce sac vous dit pas exactement
jeudi les efforts de renouvellement du
marché
est-ce qu'on a raison ou est-ce qu'on a
tort parce que je prends un exemple
aujourd'hui
pendant des années on nous a expliqué
que l'état devait reculer
c'était donc ça c'est la pensée
dominante
l'état doit reculer l'état trop d'argent
il intervient machin la société le
marché doivent décider pour l'essentiel
des choses l'utah d'avoir un petit rôle
mais aussi petit que possible également
changé la crise et a totalement changé
maintenant c'est les gens se tournent
vers l'état est décédé de ça qu'il doit
faire le testament
je suis sûr que cette vieille idée de la
gauche qu'on disait quand le pont décalé
est revenu enfin je voulais vous montrer
un petit dessin pour terminer parce que
le temps presse et qu'on aille sur le
dernier débat mais ça rejoint ce que
vous disiez sur la crise vous l'avez
forcément vu ce dessin de cac dans
l'opinion genevois aux côtés de françois
hollande
et ça tombe sur un mec de droite un tous
ces milliards qui sortent des caisses de
l'état qu'on peut investir dans
l'économie saloperie de virus et on voit
derrière bruno bruno le maire mais ma
question elle est toute simple vous
voulez pas pour françois hollande c'est
ce qu'on dit parfois mais vous n'êtes
pas la question parce que je voulais
bien mais vous savez le qui va être
candidat je ne sais pas et vous non plus
donc je ne roule pour personne à ce
stade dans la mesure où je n'ai pas de
candidat il n'y en a pas
personne ne s'est déclaré et le jour y
en aura une candidate un candidat
j'aviserai
pour l'instant c'est une association
c'est les membres de l'association qui
décide qui travaille sur un projet c'est
très clair merci beaucoup ri cela alors
geoffrey avoue rester avec nous que
s'est il passé ces dernières 24 heures à
l'assemblée nationale c'est lors de la
chronique de thomas des prêts forte
demande vous le savez citoyenne pour
être associé à la décision politique et
bien justement aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
une plate forme a été mise en ligne
n'est ce pas thomas oui exactement
myriam une plateforme pour recueillir
les pétitions des citoyens et c'est une
petite révolution
si je vous raconte pourquoi alors on a
tous ou presque dans notre vie déjà
signé une pétition contre l'arrêt d'une
émission de télé ou alors pour manger
plus de frites à la cantine
non plus sérieusement le droit de
pétition c'est un sujet qui vient très
régulièrement au coeur de l'actualité et
l'assemblée a du coup décidé de rénover
son droit de pétition qui existait
depuis des années en l'inscrivant sur un
site internet pétition pour assemblée
nationale.fr sur cette plateforme
il est dorénavant possible aux citoyens
d'inscrire leur propre pétition et de
les voter
c'était ce que souhaitait emmanuel
macron lors de son discours au congrès
de versailles en 2017
je souhaite que le droit de pétition
soit revu afin que l'expression directe
de nos concitoyens soient mieux prises
en compte et que les propositions des
français puissent être présentés à la
représentation nationale
bonjour silverlight herrmann bonjour
vous êtes vice-président de l'assemblée
très engagé sur les sujets de règlement
et de la modernisation de l'assemblée
concrètement comment elle s'organise
cette plateforme alors concrètement et
vous vous connectez des pétitions et des
thématiques de pétitions s'ouvre dès
lors que c'était mettre ces pétitions
atteignent 100 milles
cette pétition est débattue dans la
commission thématique et qui est
compétente et au dessus de 500 milles la
conférence des présidents est saisi pour
un débat en hémicycle
mais cinq cent mille signatures avant
d'avoir le droit d'être inscrits à
l'ordre du jour de l'hémicycle ce n'est
pas inatteignable
non pas du tout regardez les chiffres
atteindre 100 milles à river à la
commission c'est tout à fait c'est tout
à fait faisable 500 me dans 30
départements
parce qu'il faut que le sujet soit
répartie on verra l'histoire le dira les
députés n'ont pas attendu cette
plateforme pour se mettre à signer des
pétitions que ce soit pour le bien-être
animal le droit de vote à 16 ans ou
encore la privatisation d'adé p mais que
pense t il de cette initiative de
l'assemblée nationale on leur a posé la
question c'est une bonne chose que
l'assemblée nationale se met aux
pétitions oui c'est une bonne chose
c'est une bonne chose que les français
le demandent et si nous en tant que
parlementaire et en tant qu'élu des
citoyens on n'est pas capable d'écouter
ce que les français nous disent c'est
embêtant il faut que les citoyens
ne se contente pas de voter tous les
cinq ans pour élire leurs députés mais
claire entre deux ils puissent saisir
l'assemblée nationale pour faire face à
la crise de confiance certains de mes
collègues pensent que la démocratie
participative peut compléter alors qu'en
réalité mines fondamentalement le mandat
représentatif bon voilà mesdames vous
voyez que le sujet ne fait pas
complètement l'unanimité toujours est il
qu'il ya déjà 6 pétition sur le site
internet de l'assemblée
la dernière mise en ligne ce soir veut
protéger les hérissons merci beaucoup
thomas tout de suite le face à face sur
un sujet qui va vous intéresser j'en
suis sûr leurs jours
[Musique]
tous doivent à ce soir entre laurent
saint martin bonsoir vous débutez la
république en marge du val de marne et
rapporteur général du budget je signale
au passage ce petit livre la fabrique de
l'impôt pour un consentement citoyens ça
vient juste de sortir chez alma éditeurs
et vous êtes face ce soir à mathieu
plane
bonsoir vous êtes économiste alors fc le
face à face qui porte ce soit sur les
aides de l'état aux entreprises vous le
savez le gouvernement a présenté son
budget en début de semaine 10 milliards
d'euros d'impôts en moins pour toutes
les sociétés sans distinction celle qui
profitent de la crise les entreprises du
numérique la grande distribution comme
celles qui sont menacées de faillite des
clés pour comprendre d'abord avant de
vous laisser la parole avec elsa monde à
garat l'état les entreprises et les
aides publiques
une équation parfois compliqué de
quelles aides parle-t-on au plus fort de
la crise l'état a pris en charge les
salaires d'une partie des français au
travers du dispositif du chômage partiel
il a par ailleurs garantie des prêts
pour les entreprises en difficulté un
fonds de solidarité a été mise en place
pour aider les secteurs très touchés par
la crise comme l'hôtellerie ou la
restauration 20 milliards d'euros ont
été débloqués pour soutenir les
entreprises dites stratégiques comme air
france et renault
enfin le gouvernement tient sa promesse
de baisse de l'imposition 10 milliards
de baisses d impôts de production
l'année prochaine un impôt sur les
sociétés est ramené à 25% d'ici à 2022
voici donc la panoplie des aides que
l'état mette en place pour ces
entreprises
pourtant sur le front social cet avis de
gros temps alors joue-t-elle le jeu
bridgestone 8 163 emplois menacés air
france 7500 postes supprimés
1233 chez nokia est un point commun ces
entreprises ont tout toucher des aides
publiques
bridgestone des aides de la région de la
communauté d'agglomération et surtout
1,8 million d'euros au titre du cic eux
le crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi
de françois hollande
air france de son côté a vu l'état lui
prêter 7 milliards d'euros pour faire
face à l'épidémie de covin 19 nokia a
touché plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros grâce au crédit d'impôt
recherche
pour certains cela ravive un débat
faut-il un meilleur ciblage des aides ou
instaurer des contreparties difficile
d'avoir des taux d'imposition différents
les conditions pourraient donc être sur
le maintien dans l'emploi
la relocalisation ou bien les enjeux
environnementaux mais le gouvernement
semble plutôt évoqué la nécessité de
créer un climat de confiance avec des
entreprises qui ont subi de plein fouet
la crise économique
laurent saint martin est ce que vous
assumez avec cette relance d'aider des
entreprises qui n'ont pas forcément
besoin alors je pense d'abord que toutes
les entreprises ont besoin d'être
accompagnés dans ce plan de relance que
ce soit la toute petite entreprise où la
grande entreprise du cac40 pour des
raisons différentes avec des
affaiblissements différents
oui parce que d'une manière ou d'une
autre un climat d'investissement et un
climat de re création d'emplois dans un
pays ça concerne l'ensemble des
entreprises même celles qui n'ont pas
forcément beaucoup perdu au moment du
confinement
évidemment tout ça est interdépendant je
voudrais juste dire par rapport à votre
reportage c'est que créer un climat de
confiance dans la reprise pour une
entreprise n'exclut en aucun cas la
notion de contrepartie moi je préfère le
terme d'engagement réciproque faut pas
opposer les deux c'est très
franco-français d'opposer les deux comme
si l'entreprise était un objet méchant
qu'on peut aider
on peut aider à survivre si seulement
elles se comportent de telle ou telle
manière je crois que c'est pas comme ça
qu'il faut raisonner faut effectivement
donné les conditions de l'investissement
dans notre pays pour créer de l'emploi
pour qu'ils aient des conditions de
marché de main qui leur soit favorable
pour concret justement les meilleures
opportunités économiques pour notre pays
et pour l'europe et en parallèle reste
exigeant vis-à-vis du monde de
l'entreprise vis-à-vis d'un certain
nombre de progrès qui sont attendus on
est dans un pays où le dialogue social
est effectivement plutôt mauvais la
plupart du temps malheureusement et je
crois qu'on pourrait s'inspirer d'autres
pays pour progresser après cette crise
sur cette voie là aider toutes les
entreprises sans les cibles et pour
créer un choc de confiance à compte la
confiance
oui j'étais konami ça compte surtout en
ce moment mais bon je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs plusieurs questions dans votre
question
là on est en temps de crise donc on est
dans un monde un peu particulier avec
des choses que sectoriel très différents
la question qui est posée c'est est ce
que finalement le plan de relance bon
ciblage
c'est une des questions qu'on peut se
poser si on prend les baisses d'impôts
de production parce que ya déjà des
aides sectorielles à tous les secteurs
qui ont été frappés très durement
l'automobile le transport aérien la
culture etc
les les impôts des impôts vont baisser
10 milliards d'euros de baisses d'impôts
de production ça le faire sans aucun
ciblage ça peut avoir un effet un effet
rapide possible via un ciblage qui est
un peu plus industriel parce que les
impôts sur la production touché un peu
plus secteur industriel non le la
question il est là c'est que je suis pas
sûr effectivement que la baisse des
impôts sur la production soit la bonne
réponse à la crise pourquoi parce que
évidemment ça a touché particulièrement
les entreprises les plus en difficulté
et c'est vrai que dans le dispositif de
relance il ya 3 milliards qui sont mis
pour le renforcement des fonds propres
or moi il me semble que dans les six
prochains mois il voir des grandes
difficultés pour les entreprises sur
leur rentabilité leur solvabilité et
donc il me semble que c'est sous calibre
et d'un renforcement des fonds propres
plats vous voulez dire que ces corps
baissant les impôts on ne traduit pas
tout de suite
mais c'était urgent fallait quoi donner
des chèques aux entreprises alors en
revanche et c'est pas une mauvaise
mesure en soit c'est une mesure de
compétitivité on sait que ça touche
plutôt l'industrie le secteur
exportateur
c'est mais c'est vrai que c'est une
mesure pérenne c'est pas une mesure de
relance une relance avait plutôt
temporaire c'est là où je reprocherais
peut-être le choix dans la relance de
faire d une baisse des impôts sur la
production et donc voilà c'est plutôt
sur cette question de ciblage et de
savoir la temporalité est ce que on
maintient ce dispositif de façon pérenne
hélas si on le fait ça veut dire à ce
moment là il faut réfléchir à la
fiscalité sur les entreprises dans leur
globalité notamment ne peut être pas
baisser l'impôt société parce que ça
veut dire voir un problème de
financement si on baisse les impôts sur
la production alors à ce moment les
votre fard trouver de nouvelles
ressources et donc il ya tous ces
enjeux-là derrière tu es pense d'abord
une précision sur les trois milliards
d'euros qui sont mises pour le
renforcement des fonds propres des
entreprises 103 milliards d'euros de
garanties d'état pour des prêts
participatifs bancaires qui vont
eux-mêmes renforcer les fonds propres
des entreprises l'effet de levier
il est de 20% que l'on construit sur des
encours bancaires en prêts participatifs
de 15 milliards d'euros pas trop tôt
c'est difficile
oui ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'on met 3 milliards d'euros pour 15
milliards d'euros dans les entreprises
séduction court terme alors qu'il en
faut expliquer ce qu'est un impôt de
production le problème de l'impôt de
production ceux qui taxent une
entreprise avant même qu'elle ait créé
de la richesse avant même qu'elle ait
démontré une capacité à faire du profit
et rien de plus injuste quand vous êtes
une entreprise que vous êtes une
personne morale quand vous taxe
uniquement parce que vous vous situez
dans un pays en est le seul pays et dans
le monde à faire ça il n'y a pas
d'équivalent contacter une entreprise
sur des bénéfices c'est tout à fait
normal
encore faut-il que ce soit dans des
proportions à peu près compétitif par
rapport aux autres pays
mais quand taxi l'entreprise juste parce
qu'elle vient mettre une usine dans vos
territoires faut pas s'étonner que les
entreprises françaises et délocaliser
pendant tant de décennies
la priorité de ce plan de relance et la
relocalisation industrielle
mathieu plane l'a bien dit il ya un
ciblage je veux pas rentrer dans la
technique mais parmi les impôts de
production effectivement est une vraie
volonté de faire revenir nos industries
dans nos pays parce que l'emploi
industriel idée qualifiée en france il
est reconnu comme tel
souvent la fiscalité confiscatoire et a
fait fuir malheureusement pendant trop
longtemps nos entreprises et revoilà le
débat sur les contreparties le ciblage
du team
il est légitime et quand c'est michel
sapin qui dit argent public gâchée par
exemple parce qu'il n'est pas un peu
hypocrite parce qu'après tout cce n'a
pas été conditionné bon il est peut-être
je sais bien qu'en fait la condition ça
complique administrative
je comprends bien ça mais il faut
changer un peu de points de vue parce
que vous parlez de là le sentiment
d'injustice qui éprouvent certaines
entreprises parce qu'elles payent des
impôts avant même d'avoir commencé à
produire mais il faut se mettre à la
place du salarié de béthune par exemple
le savez de béthune et on lui annonce la
fermeture à la plainte reprise gagne de
l'argent et estonie l'argent beaucoup
d'argent mais les gros pouce est fermé
et c'est fermé sa ferme et à béthune je
connais un peu l'endroit la safege et
800 emplois je pense à 860
c'est très important pour la demandez
vous pourquoi et quand j'étais là mais
on en franchit les relayeurs je t'amène
le oui mais vous êtes en train de nous
expliquer que on n'y peut rien non j'ai
certainement pas 10 ans et mais il faut
se mettre à la place des gens concernés
ça qui est important
de la même manière que vous l'avez fait
pour les entreprises le patron qui
payent alors qu'il arrivait encore c'est
insupportable pour les gens et c'est moi
qui suis pour les coller de marché je
trouve que c'est la meilleure manière de
le miner la réputation de cette économie
en imposant ce genre de choses aux
salariés donc vous dites il faut pas de
conditions peut-être qu'il faudrait
quand même une légère conditions qui
dirait qu'il ferait pas de conditions
favorables à ce que bridgestone rendre
l'argent des aides
oui oui si on s'appelle plus de 3
millions d'euros oui bien sûr si au
moment ce cas ils ont décidé sur moment
du calibre il y avait une possibilité de
recouvrement oui je pense que c'est une
bonne mesure effectivement de faire
rembourser les aides de l'état
quand on ne respecte pas effectivement
ce pourquoi l'entreprise a été cet
argent nous propose que je suis ici ce
que je dis juste que moi aussi ma seule
boussole c'est l'emploi et ce sont les
salariés c'est pas le patronat fo
parents dans cette caricature la
revanche et on veut que les emplois
reste dans notre pays il faut se
demander pourquoi brixton ferme en
france et pas ailleurs et un moment
l'attractivité d'un territoire il faut
quand même accepter que c'est une
réalité dans l'économie de marché si
vous êtes pour l'économie de marché vous
devez comprendre que une entreprise
intégrée en france
en france des salaires en birmanie ça va
être formidable on en entend pas besoin
de tomber dans la caricature vous savez
bien qu'on a besoin savait bien qu'on a
besoin d'une fiscalité qui soit à peu
près 100 ha par rapport aux autres pays
si vous êtes pour l'économie de marché
vous êtes pour ce parce que voilà le
temps passe vite en contre oduction est
due selon mathieu plane
moi je le débat il porte sur la question
des ciblages et des contreparties
éventuelles
il n'y avait pas de contrepartie pendant
le cic il n'y a pas ou peu de ciblage
dans ce plan de relance
d'abord est-ce que c'est possible de le
faire parce que juridiquement
bruissement est possible si c'est aussi
par respect aux 35 heures les
allégements de cotisations étaient
soumis à un accord dans l'entreprise
donc c'est possible
le problème il est là il est con je
pense comprendre lancé un plan de
relance se fait dans l'urgence et dans
l'urgence il difficile d'exiger des
contreparties sachant qu'on sait pas
comment sera l'économie même dans deux
mois trois mois ou un an et donc vous
pouvez pas vous engager très fortement
sur l'emploi sur l'investissement
pouvait pas administrer des choix qui
vont être faits dans les entreprises
là les impôts sur l'action c'est un peu
un peu différent parce que c'est un
engagement pérenne et peut-être que
justement il ya un enjeu de
relocalisation on aurait pu dire au plus
grand groupe
justement de s'engager sur le
rapatriement d'une partie de leur
production en contrepartie de baisses
d'impôts sur la production
ça c'est des choses qui peut être
intéressante mais ça et ça c'est
vraiment un point sur lequel aussi je
voudrais insister si je pense que la
meilleure chose quand même à faire c'est
mettre de la cogestion dans les
entreprises ont plutôt que d'exiger de
la contrepartie que l'état et voirie
squattait la participation des salariés
plus de pouvoir des salariés dans la
direction d'antalis dans les conseils
d'administration conditions pourquoi
vous ne l'avez pas fait et au fond
pourquoi vous ne citez pas davantage à
mettre le salarié au coeur de la gestion
d'abord un débat parlementaire qui va
commencer à partir de mardi prochain
donc et pas de on l'a fait on l'a pas
fait il ya le gouvernement qui a
présenté un projet de loi maintenant on
a trois mois pour discuter d'un texte
récent sur la question de conditionner
la baisse des impôts de production en
maintien d'un certain nombre d'emplois
ou à la création d'un certain nombre
d'emplois pour moi ça c'est le bis
repetita de ce qu'on a toujours essayé
de faire qui ne marche pas donc ça je
n'y crois pas la condition où la
conditionnalité de la baisse de la
production la baisse d'impôts de
production s'est directement
l'attractivité
fiscale donc si les entreprises viennent
dans notre pays demain re localiser des
emplois industriels parce qu'il ya de
meilleur fichiers la politique pourquoi
est ce que vous savez pourquoi le cicr
n'a pas créé d'emplois parce que le
climat de défiance permanent entre les
entreprises et le pouvoir public d'alors
à empêcher justement toute capacité à
créer de l'investissement et de l'emploi
pendant cinq ans on s'est empêché de se
donner les conditions d'investissements
et d'emplois dans notre pays on va pas
refaire les mêmes erreurs
jeudi pas convaincue je vous en a écrit
un peu jésus juste pendant 50 et suivie
dans trois ans est ce que je voudrais
juste dire sera deuxième chose là par
contre je suis d'accord avec mathieu
plane
le partage de la valeur doit être une
exigence et là par contre ça peut être
totalement et législatif avec la
participation dans les conseils
d'administration oui aussi je pense
qu'on peut à la fois rendre plus
puissant je pense qu'on peut rendre plus
puissants l'avis du cse par exemple pour
parler très concrètement dans
l'entreprise je partage votre avis et je
crois que le partage de la valeur doit
aussi être quelque chose qui doit être
renforcé à la bouger sur deux lignes
peut-être économique ça sera le mot de
la fin vous le pensez aux postures de se
débarrasser dans les organes de
direction
la moitié de sa vie on n'y est pas un
tout cas c'est une proposition sur la
table
merci messieurs faites revenir débats de
cette relance we have been social qui
fonctionne
le débat budgétaire ne fait que
commencer vous en êtes le chef
d'orchestre et ça commencera à partir de
moine hôpitaux dès ce mardi et on est en
octobre donc dans en commission et dans
l'hémicycle très bientôt je rappelle le
titre de votre livre anti matheron le
ton est donné mais c'est plus subtil
à l'intérieur ce sont des chroniques que
vous avez publié dans libération les
jeux publié chez stock
merci messieurs très belle soirée sur
lcp et à demain
[Musique]